el 12 de noviembre bienvenidos a
economía quién france24 y recibo con
mucho gusto al especialista daniel
hablando ramírez daniela muy bienvenida
brasil mantuvo sus índices de extrema
pobreza en el 2019 a las muy buenas
noches mire el país más grande de
américa latina tiene 210 millones de
habitantes y de ese total 13,6 millones
viven en la pobreza extrema esto quiere
decir que la tasa de pobreza extrema es
decir quienes sobreviven con menos de 2
dólares al día quedó exactamente igual a
la de 2018 que fue del 6,5 por ciento y
que había sido un máximo histórico la
tasa de pobreza o sea los que viven con
5,5 dólares por día quedó en 24 7% en
2019 significa que tuvo un pequeño
descenso frente al año anterior la cifra
que habrá que ver a lan ahora es la de
2020 porque en esas estadísticas
divulgadas hoy que estamos mostrando no
se está sumando ni un solo pobre o pobre
extremo que se haya atribuido a la paz
vamos ahora a argentina y es que la
inflación en este país en octubre fue la
más alta de todo lo transcurrido de este
año sí señor los precios al consumidor
en el décimo mes del año subieron 38 por
ciento frente a septiembre pero si se
compara con el mismo mes del año pasado
reflejan un alza del 37 2% recordemos
que argentina es uno de los países más
inflacionarios de la región y en 2020
cursó su tercer año en recesión y los
precios de la canasta familiar son una
muestra de ello en 2018 los precios al
consumidor acumularon una subida
superior al 47% esta fue la más alta en
27 años y en 2019 se dispararon al 53 8%
y el récord superaba el de casi tres
décadas y este año a las autoridades
económicas apuntan a que la inflación
será del 35,8 por ciento y que será un
poco más alta en 2021 lo que más se está
subiendo es las prendas de vestir y el
calzado así como también los alimentos
india anunció hoy un millonario paquete
para reactivar su economía en este país
es uno de los más golpeados en el mundo
por la pandemia si serán 35.000 millones
de dólares en inversiones que buscan
impulsar el empleo la demanda de los
consumidores también la manufactura la
agricultura y las exportaciones todo
esto afectado por la pandemia del
coronavirus el ministro de finanzas
explicó que dentro de esas inversiones
habrá una pequeña partida de 120
millones de dólares para desarrollar una
vacuna contra kobe de 19 por parte del
departamento de biotecnología del
gobierno justo un día antes el gabinete
del primer ministro narendra modi aprobó
27 mil millones de dólares en incentivos
durante 5 años esto para los fabricantes
de diez sectores de la economía entre
ellos los automóviles las autopartes los
productos farmacéuticos los textiles y
también los alimentos
daniela estados unidos prohibió las
inversiones en ciertas empresas chinas
qué información tienes a quienes aplica
estas prohibiciones alan y de esta
prohibición aplica sobre 31 empresas que
son propiedad o están controladas por
las
las armadas de ese país por ejemplo dos
de las más grandes son china la china
telecom y china mobile también el
fabricante de equipos de vigilancia
gigavisión la razón que dio el
departamento de seguridad nacional es
que la decisión sirve para proteger a
los inversionistas estadounidenses del
aporte involuntario de capital destinado
a mejorar las capacidades de los
servicios de inteligencia chinos y
agrega que actualmente estos servicios
se dirigen a ciudadanos y empresas
estadounidenses a través de operaciones
cibernéticas de esta manera ningún
ciudadano estadounidense puede comprar
acciones directamente oa través de
fondos de inversión en estas firmas a
partir del próximo 11 de enero - con los
indicadores económicos de la jornada el
aumento de casos de kobe de 19 volvió a
ser protagonista en wall street que
cerró hoy con pérdidas en sus
principales índices
europa y acabó la racha de fuertes alzas
de las tres jornadas anteriores como
reacción al anuncio sobre la vacuna
contra el coronavirus
américa latina siguió el mismo rumbo la
bolsa de sao paulo por ejemplo se dio
más del 2% vámonos con la cifra del día
de daniela una buena noticia para los
países pobres 500 millones de dólares de
se comprometieron los países
desarrollados en el foro la paz pues
estos recursos son para que la vacuna
contra el comité 19 les llegue a todos
por igual en estos países de escasos
recursos bien daniela muchas gracias por
el recorrido económico y ustedes muchas
gracias por su compañía siga con
nosotros en francés 24
y
[Música]